tu es vraiment
un sport qui qui prend tout qui regarde
tout de toi puis moi je serais pas faire
ça Marie piardière a réussi l'ascension
du K2 deuxième plus haut se met au monde
après l'Everest mais sans compter le
plus périlleux un alpiniste sur 4 en
moyenne hyper la vie dont le Québécois
Richard Cartier l'été dernier tu as beau
avoir tout gérer avoir la meilleure
température avoir le meilleur équipement
connaître et technique et avoir une
expertise de feu il y a des choses qui
sont hors de ton contrôle puis ça mais à
un moment donné il faut juste que tu
l'acceptes si j'ai un travail intérieur
à faire avant de partir de me dire
jusqu'où est-ce que je suis prête à
aller c'est une possibilité que je
revienne pas est-ce que je suis en paix
avec ça la Québécoise de 36 ans habite
présentement au Qatar et il travaille
comme experte en gestion de crise
son mentor pour escalader le cas 2 c'est
normal purgea devenu populaire sur
Netflix pour avoir enchaîné de 14
sommets de 8 mm en 6 mois le secret de
son succès des plans ABCD pour faire
face à toutes sortes d'imprévus une
roche qui passe la qui traverse la tente
qui déchire la tente au complet puis
nous autres on est dans les trois puis
on voit ses concerts
Marie-Pierre diarnet a survécu un
tsunami à l'âge de 19 ans alors qu'elle
était en vacances en Thaïlande
des hauteurs presque au temps presque
aussi grande que la peur de l'eau qui
est pour moi aussi un terrain un peu
glissant depuis sa mère l'accompagne
dans tous ses projets c'est là où c'est
là où c'est longitude les pires
scénarios c'est introduit dans nos têtes
puis là ben on pense que finalement on
la verra peut-être pas je pars le 25
décembre je m'en vais au Chili et de là
on s'en va en Antarctique je m'en vais
faire la dernière phase de mon projet
apex woman project Marie-Pierre diarnais
a mis sur pied le projet apex woman qui
comprend l'ascension de 5 sommets
généralement peu atteints par des femmes
et là déjà gravi le Horos de salados en
Amérique du Sud en 2020 les vrais
restent au printemps 2021 le cas 2 cet
été il lui reste le massif wintzen et le
mot cibli tous en Antarctique je pense
qu'il ne trouve pas
Radio-Canada Montréal